hugh grant et squeeze aujourd'hui un
stosur qu'est ce que c'est que ça bordel
on a récemment atteint les 1 million
pleuvoir sur twitter et pour vous
remercier pour vous prouver ma bonne
franchise j'ai décidé de passer au
détecteur de mensonge alors annoncé dans
la dramatique le sujet commencer la
vidéo on y va ceci est donc un détecteur
de mensonges électrique et plus tu m'as
envoyé ici plus tu te prends une grosse
décharge mais on va y aller d'abord il
va scanner mes battements de coeur je
m'appelle lui car j'ai 19 ans j'adore
mes abonnés maintenant je lis une
question j'appuie là je dis ma réponse
et on voit ce qui se passe
as tu déjà trompé guen avec jumbo pas du
tout mais oui je suis un homme fidèle
bah oui fais-tu partie de l'illuminati
oui
est ce que vous en êtes au courant pour
ta petite histoire avec heavy non c'est
le contre coup tu ne le saura jamais
mais m'a prescrit seul à la maison on va
parler tu penses tu avoir une carrière
caché dans le dessin oui elle s'est tue
bah voilà bah ouais merci et humour et d
une autre façon de se passer par la
fenêtre mais tu le sais bien as-tu déjà
eu une attirance sexuelle pour autre
chose qu'un être humain non jumbo je te
promets que nous maintenant je veux dire
au bout avec ma copine surplus avec
crouch à ploeren de bakwa parce que ta
[ __ ] c'est parce que tu crois que
c'est ce qui m'attire et c'était ton
vendredi nous mettre ma main dedans
comme ça il caressait fait pas peur vous
aussi votre chef de tir quand il est
comme ça de faire ça partout comme ça
peux-tu rendre l'argent aux abonnés
si l'an passé dans le rouge ça veut dire
qu'il faut pas c'est d'enlever se dire
qu'il aurait préféré ranger aux abonnés
voilà l'argent
je leur ai appris en jouant la bonne
paye ok je n'ai pas de question
cordialement
cordialement de proctor tu veux répondre
sur le boucan des mots ou duo je n'ai
pas de question à la fin faut pas
répondre
attends mais là c'est une énigme quoi
sans déconner note john sherlock et
c'est tout de suite pour nous dire
qu'est-ce qu'il faut répondre je n'ai
pas de question cordialement camp dial
mans question de pas neige à sées
compris on sait parfaitement où plutôt
coquet aux missions suivantes à saint
vallier nigma la course quel est le
secret de sweety pour arriver à tout
supporter elle mange beaucoup de citron
ça va passer moi je suis pas sûr je sais
pas ce que c'est sûr secret comment tu
veux mais aucune pitié
de même pourquoi tes cheveux défie-t-il
la loi de la gravité parce que je n'aime
pas faire comme tout le monde elles sont
passées là bas juste parce qu'ils sont
moches voilà c'est à dire comme réponse
moi oui as-tu déjà frappé jumbo non
l'été s'est finalement fait savoir
fais ça tu as encore 1,2 pour dormir
je suis un gamin je suis un grand homme
nature donc non on s'est fait griller
bichon c'est pas grave tout va bien
c'est bichon mondiaux pour dormir
est-ce que tu dessines vraiment aussi
mal ou tu fais exprès je fais totalement
exprès quand je vous dis que je fais des
vraies oeuvres d'art c'est que c'est la
vérité mais je fais exprès en vidéo et
tout j'aime pas trop les pâtes et les
gens par mon talent tu veux si tu te
plaît à critiquer mais des sabres qui
avaient confiance en toi qui te prenait
par la main comme ça tu m'as déçue je te
récettes d'inoa mensonge
j'ai un très petit zizi du coude pour
une fois j'aurais aimé me prend deux
lectrices it et tu vas tu aurais pas pu
le faire rouge non et je déteste le truc
est ce que le départ de zain a attristé
et voudrais-tu prendre sa place ça n'a
pas du tout attristé et je ne veux
nullement prendre sa place l'eev secrète
plus qui vous aider vous allez j'ai
toujours voulu faire partie de ce groupe
je voyais bien au côté de harry stiles
et de la gamme g plus son nom on des
photos avec des filles chanter sur scène
qu'est ce que tu as fait de talent pas
vous tu l'as tuée sadique juge
totalement innocent dans cette histoire
voilà elles portées disparues ok tu es
et on pas y est elle est là depuis tous
ces petits des eaux
vous l'avez jamais vu tu vas vraiment
chez le coiffeur où tu nous manques je
vais vraiment chez le coiffeur mais je
sais pas trop comment le prendre du coup
c'est que jamais décidée à temps mais
lui il fait un rap contenders bientôt
nommé c'est sûr tu fais toujours fille
holly oui oui je prenne de la vérité du
rac le piton ben oui
je vois pas menti encore une vérité
humiliant de dévoiler au public
regardez c'est plus de cette nuit voyou
pas là juste là juste là à vous trois
quarts des abonnés ces défauts compte de
ta famille pas du tout mais qui fressin
franchement maigri par une grippe a une
fois de plus te plaît là ok j'avoue je
salue donc moi c'est très gentil feature
suis là aujourd'hui c'est grâce à eux
alors ça vous voyez à quel point ça dit
la merde ce truc est ce que tu aimes
souffrir sitev électrique te fait du
bien oui parlons nous dit nous tous non
j'ai horreur de ça je déteste c'est
ignoble
non il a menti j'ai pratiqué depuis des
mois énorme for that elle même un style
anglais nul
oui mais bon déjà c'est la fin de cette
vidéo avec ce [ __ ] de détecteur de
mensonges électrique qui finalement n'a
fait que de m'envoyer des décharges dans
toute la vidéo comme ça il y aller il
m'a plus bas n'est que je n'étais vannes
et depuis que je suis née en fait oui je
galère à dire cette phrase reste avoir
regardé n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo si
ce genre de vidéos vous plaît sur des
petits trucs pas des jeux vidéo et des
petits trucs un peu à part un peu con
j'essayais d'en trouver d'autres outils
et même vous vous en trouver d'autres
envoyez les moi on s'attend à tomber
dans une prochaine vidéo chat monde pis
la légende dit qu'un soir de plaine
étoiles ya pas de lune fait chier un
homme trouvera une grotte secrète entre
les fougères et les mauvaises herbes
c'est quelque chose de très beau il
aurait intérêt tentateur s'il ya tout
qui va cramer m'indiquer toute la
légende de cons